welcome back to cbs this morning the
manhattan district attorney's office
says it's investigating a physical
confrontation
between a white woman and a black
teenager caught on camera
jazz musician keon harold took this
video in the lobby of a new york city
hotel
where he and his 14 year old son were
staying it shows the woman tackling the
teenager after accusing him
of taking her cell phone which he did
not do the confrontation is drawing
comparisons to
other recent false accusations against
black people nikki batiste is at the
arlo hotel
nikki good morning adriana good morning
the hotel says it did call the police
after the incident
about the woman's conduct and the nypd
confirms harold
has filed a harassment complaint the
hotel also admits
more could have been done to de-escalate
the dispute
that's fine literally are you kidding me
musician keon harold says he and his son
keon jr had just exited the elevator
when they were confronted by this
unidentified woman in the hotel lobby
this lady was you know irate and
you know literally just suggested that
my son had somehow acquired her cell
phone which is you know ridiculous we
literally never seen this lady
in the video the woman continues to
accuse the teen of having her
iphone and a person who identifies
themselves as the manager appears to
approach the teen
i'm the manager of the hotel i don't
care they never asked any questions
they demanded his phone which is
ridiculous
my son is 14 years old he has the right
to to have his phone and he also has the
right not to show it
let's go as harold and his son leave the
lobby the woman
follows them he says she then scratched
him on his hand and
tackled and grabbed his son please get
my phone back i can't
i cannot no harold said he was told by
the hotel that the woman's phone was
returned by an
uber driver shortly afterward attorney
ben crump who is representing the family
is now calling on the manhattan district
attorney
to charge the woman with battery and
assault this culture of implicit bias
that
so many people have it needs to stop i'm
going to tell them there's an
african-american man threatening my life
just seven months ago this video of amy
cooper calling 9-1-1
on bird watcher christian cooper went
viral highlighting the issue of false
accusations made against black people
harold said his son is traumatized but
he shared the video to shed light on
these incidents
we know the stories of so many other
people wrongly accused
so well so you know i feel like
it just needs to be dealt with in this
country so we can have a fair shot
in a statement the arlo hotel said it
was deeply disheartened about this
incident of baseless accusation
prejudice and assault against an
innocent guest
the company says it's committed to
making sure this never happens again
at its hotels tarika nikki thank you